Sur l'air de "Freed From Desire"
-DES MOTS DES MOTS
LA CA DEVIENT CHAUD
WOMEN ON FIRE...
-La bataille
contre la réforme des retraites
a commencé dans la rue
avec une mobilisation record
dans toute la France.
Alors que le débat s'ouvre
à l'Assemblée nationale,
les députés s'activent
sur le terrain
pour faire valoir
leurs arguments.
D'un côté,
les parlementaires expliquent
que la réforme
est incontournable.
-Ca ne me dérange pas
qu'on me dise :
"Je suis opposé,
j'aimerais aussi
"entendre des propositions
alternatives."
-On peut pas être
dans un déni de réalité.
Il faut prendre ces sujets
à bras-le-corps.
C'est ça, le courage.
-De l'autre, les opposants
qui s'activent pour gagner
la bataille de l'opinion.
-Qui était à la manifestation
jeudi dernier ?
-On est contre
parce qu'on part du principe
que c'est injuste et injustifié.
-Députés en action
pour ou contre
la mère des réformes
du deuxième quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron.
Rires
Député du Rhône,
Jean-Luc Fugit est un
des rares parlementaires
Renaissance
qui va au contact des électeurs
pour défendre la réforme.
-Chaque député organise
la rencontre avec ses concitoyens
comme il le conçoit.
-Sur la retraite, ils vont
pas trop au feu, quand même.
-Je pense que c'est important
et c'est important aussi de pouvoir
percevoir les désaccords
qu'il y a,
ils font partie
du débat démocratique,
et donc, avant le débat
au Parlement
la semaine prochaine
en séance publique,
je pense qu'il est intéressant
que je ressente
la réalité de celles et ceux
que j'ai rencontrés
ou que je vais rencontrer
dans ces soirées débats.
-Ce soir-là, à Condrieu,
dans la banlieue de Lyon...
-Bonsoir.
-Vous allez bien ?
-...il va jouer les VRP
d'une réforme...
-Ca va ?
-Salut.
-...qui a du mal à passer.
*-Bonsoir à toutes
et tous, et puis, ben,
merci d'être venus
à cette assemblée citoyenne.
Je vais passer la parole
à Jean-Michel,
il se présente
et présente les données.
*-Bonsoir à toutes
et à tous.
Avant d'avoir votre taux plein...
-Premier acte : convaincre
que cette réforme
est indispensable.
*-La pérennité
de notre régime de retraite
n'est pas assurée.
On a, en 1970, 3 cotisants
pour un seul retraité.
En 2023, aujourd'hui,
1,7 cotisant pour 1 retraité.
En 2050, ce sera 1,4 cotisant
pour 1 retraité.
-Et donc, la suite semble
couler de source :
il faut reculer à 64 ans
l'âge de départ à la retraite
et exiger 43 ans
de cotisation
pour toucher sa pension
sans décote.
*-Je vous remercie
de votre attention.
-Merci, Jean-Michel.
Applaudissements
Qui veut ? Ca peut être
des avis, des questions,
des demandes de précisions.
Si on les a, on vous les donnera.
-La masse considérable
d'exonérations
de charges des entreprises
ne serait-elle pas
une possible répartition
autre de l'effort ?
-Le choix qui est fait,
c'est d'aller
vers la société du plein emploi.
Il ne faut pas
asphyxier vos entreprises,
donc on ne fait pas porter
l'effort aux entreprises.
-Je suis aide-soignante
depuis plus de 23 ans.
Les épaules et le dos
ramassent énormément.
A partir de 55 ans, on est
en maladie professionnelle.
-Ne faut-il pas, à un moment,
dans notre société, poser aussi
autour de la table un sujet :
comment on gère
les fins de carrière ?
-Pourquoi ne pas le faire avant ?
On a l'impression que les choses
sont faites à l'envers.
-Moi, je suis contre
cette réforme.
Pour moi, c'est inacceptable,
ça provoque de la colère chez moi.
Quelle est la contrainte
que l'on met aux entreprises
pour qu'effectivement,
elles assurent
l'embauche des seniors ?
-Ca ne me dérange pas
qu'on me dise :
"Je suis opposé, j'aimerais
entendre des alternatives",
mais il y a peut-être des idées
à aller chercher
dans des pays voisins
ou scandinaves
sur comment on améliore
la prise en compte
des fins de carrière
ou de ce qu'on appelle les seniors.
Je suis sincèrement ravi
d'avoir eu
ce temps d'échange avec vous.
Merci et bonne soirée.
-Le député a-t-il convaincu ?
Pas sûr.
-Convaincu d'aller
manifester demain.
Ca confirme bien
ce que j'en pensais.
-Moi, je vais travailler
peut-être 2-3 ans de plus
alors que j'ai déjà
mes 43 années,
donc c'est injuste.
C'est très injuste.
-Aujourd'hui,
72 % des Français
sont opposés à la réforme,
jusqu'à 93 %
chez les seuls actifs.
Autant dire que les députés
qui la combattent
ont la tâche plus facile.
A Paris,
Danielle Simonnet
s'est voulue inventive
pour peser dans le débat.
-Installez-vous, approchez-vous.
Tiens, mets-toi là, comme ça...
Ca va, depuis la manif ?
Il faisait froid, hein !
Oh là là là là là là !
Ah ben, c'est bien de venir.
-Ici, des sympathisants LFI,
mais pas seulement.
Il y a aussi des voisins,
des frères et soeurs de militants
qui ont voulu en savoir plus.
-Bienvenue pour ce petit
café populaire retraites.
Dans cette grande bataille
contre la réforme des retraites,
en plus des meetings,
des manifestations,
des soutiens à la grève,
on a décidé aussi d'organiser
des petites réunions de quartier.
Là, vous avez le projet de loi.
-Premier atelier :
en revenir au texte de la réforme
et au fameux article 7
de la loi de finances rectificative
de la Sécurité sociale
qui n'a aucune ambiguïté.
-C'est deux ans de plus,
ça, c'est terrible,
et c'est trois mois de plus
en coti...
En annuités par an,
donc ça veut dire
prolonger encore
le travail de ceux
qui sont fatigués.
-Mais au-delà du fond,
ce qui les révolte,
c'est la méthode utilisée
pour faire passer
cette réforme.
-Ce qui est scandaleux,
c'est évidemment
l'article 47.1, puisque là,
c'est une volonté
de faire qu'il y ait
le moins de débat possible
parce qu'ils ont tellement peur
du mouvement dans la rue
et ils ont tellement peur,
y compris de leur propre majorité,
ils tiennent rien, c'est une volonté
uniquement du président,
qu'ils veulent faire des trucs
très rapides.
-Alors la député
va essayer de transformer
son auditoire
en ambassadeurs de la lutte.
Autrement dit :
leur donner
des armes rhétoriques
pour contrer les arguments
des pro-réformes.
-L'argument qu'ils nous disent,
c'est : "Faut faire cette réforme
"parce qu'on commence à avoir
plus de retraités que d'actifs
"en raison de l'évolution
démographique."
Est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un
qui a envie de donner
des contre-arguments
à cet argument du gouvernement ?
-La productivité,
elle a été multipliée,
je crois, par 8,
depuis les années 60.
Donc à un moment donné,
on se demande pourquoi
on travaille,
pour qui, j'allais dire ?
Est-ce que c'est pour nous,
pour permettre
d'avoir des salaires
et des retraites décents
ou est-ce que c'est
pour les actionnaires du CAC 40 ?
"-Il faut sauver notre système
"de retraites par répartition."
Qui veut contrer cet argument-là ?
-D'après le COR, il y a pas
de problème particulier.
-Le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites, il dit quoi ?
-Il dit qu'a priori,
le déficit ne sera effectif
que dans les années 28 minimum.
-Et 12 milliards.
-12 milliards.
-Et qu'actuellement,
il est excédentaire,
notre système de retraites.
-Au final, on se promet
de créer une caisse
de grève pour soutenir les actions
et de se retrouver en manifestation.
S'opposer sans manifester,
c'est le numéro d'équilibriste
que réalise dans l'Eure
le député RN.
Pour être bien compris
de ses électeurs,
Kévin Mauvieux a clarifié les choses
sur sa permanence
et il va leur expliquer
en porte-à-porte.
Tracts en mains...
et chiffres à l'appui.
Un chien aboie.
-Mettre les gens au boulot
jusqu'à 64 ans
quand on a 17 % de chômeurs
chez les moins de 30 ans
et qu'à partir de 55 ans,
il y a qu'une personne sur deux
qui bosse...
-Tout à fait.
-Voilà, tout est dit.
On ferait mieux de trouver du boulot
à ceux qui en ont besoin
avant de demander à ceux
qui ont 62 ans
de travailler deux ans de plus.
-Tout à fait.
Et c'est des acquis sociaux
que les anciens ont gagnés.
C'est lamentable
de perdre tout ça,
et il faut qu'on se batte...
-Alors que c'est pas nécessaire.
-Non parce qu'on voit
que le pauvre s'appauvrit
et que le riche s'enrichit.
Quelque chose ne va pas.
-Merci pour l'accueil.
-Pour se démarquer
dans l'opposition,
il a une botte secrète :
la motion référendaire
déposée
par les députés RN.
-Nous, au Rassemblement national,
on a déposé un texte à l'Assemblée
pour demander
à ce que la réforme des retraites
soit faite par référendum.
Et lundi après-midi,
les députés vont tous voter
pour ou contre ce truc-là.
Donc en gros,
au Rassemblement national,
on va voter pour un référendum.
Espérons que les autres le fassent.
-C'est le seul endroit
où on peut s'exprimer.
Je suis vraiment
pour le référendum.
-Bonjour.
-Pourtant favorable au référendum,
la NUPES a annoncé
ne pas vouloir voter une motion
issue du Rassemblement national,
mais Kévin Mauvieux pense que rien
n'est perdu pour autant.
-Vous avez, au début,
il y a deux ou trois semaines,
j'étais pessimiste,
à l'Assemblée nationale,
quand j'écoutais les autres députés,
et je me disais
qu'elle allait passer.
Aujourd'hui, il y a des députés
Les Rébublicains qui disaient
qu'ils étaient pour
et qui veulent voter contre.
Ils sentent que ça saoule les gens.
-Soutenir ou pas la réforme,
c'est en effet le dilemme
de bon nombre de députés LR.
Et c'est le cas de celui
de la première circonscription
des Vosges.
Quand il va prendre le pouls
de la situation,
Stéphane Viry
sent bien
que certains
de ses électeurs
y sont très favorables.
-J'ai travaillé jusqu'à 69 ans.
J'en suis pas mort.
Je suis encore là, à 75 ans-76.
-C'est peut-être pour ça.
-Exactement, le travail...
La valeur travail
m'a donné du punch.
-Mais il est tout de même surpris
par certains cas individuels.
-En voilà une
qui veut pas prendre sa retraite.
-Elle a pourtant l'âge.
Propos inaudibles
-T'as bossé à quel âge ?
-J'ai commencé...
J'avais quel âge ?
15 ans-16 ans.
Et quand je suis venue sur Epinal
avec mon mari,
j'ai perdu quatre ans.
-Donc t'as commencé à 15 ans,
et là, à 63 ans,
tu peux pas encore partir ?
-Non, j'aurais pas mon taux plein.
-Comment tu vis la situation ?
-C'est un peu difficile.
J'aimerais avoir ma retraite
maintenant.
-Donc c'est 67 ans, pour toi ?
-Oui.
-Ah oui, quatre ans, encore !
-On arrivera peut-être
avec le déambulateur au travail.
Ils rient.
-Votera, votera pas ?
Devant ses partisans,
le député LR
dit encore hésiter.
En tout cas, ne pas donner
un blanc-seing au gouvernement.
-Ce projet de loi est perfectible,
mais on ne peut pas reprocher
au gouvernement
de mettre la question
sur la table.
Qui ne pense pas qu'il y a
des inégalités,
que celles et ceux qui ont subi
une profession dure
puissent partir plus tôt,
qu'on tienne davantage compte
de la durée de cotisation
plutôt que de l'âge légal ?
C'est là-dessus qu'il faut avancer.
-Oublier le totem des 64 ans
tout en allongeant
la durée de cotisation serait,
selon Stéphane Viry,
sans doute plus juste.
-Je voulais vous dire,
pour la retraite.
C'est plutôt la durée de cotisation
qu'il faut augmenter, pas l'âge.
-Je suis totalement d'accord.
La durée de cotisation plutôt
que l'âge légal, tu vois ?
Une fois que t'as donné ta quotepart
de 43, on te fout la paix.
-Oui.
-Autrement, tu perds 44, 45, etc.
Donc la durée de cotisation,
pour moi,
c'est la mère des réformes.
En plus, l'âge légal,
ça énerve tout le monde.
-Oui, oui.
-Ca met la rogne
et c'est pas le système
le plus juste.
-On est loin de la ligne du parti.
Pourtant, ces voix
des Républicains
s'annoncent capitales
dans le processus.
La majorité présidentielle
va en avoir besoin
pour faire voter sa réforme
sans passer en force.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA